inside we have hector mejia with even
more of an inside look hector good
morning to you sir
hey there john good morning to you and
you know vegas never misses an
excuse to party so i have a feeling that
they will have a lot of surprises
tonight when circa opens at midnight and
right now we are inside
the brand new steakhouse here this is
barry's downtown prime steakhouse where
a big part of the experience here is
some privacy so
check this out right here we have a
pretty cool dining area but for those
who may want to rent the space out all
they got to do is
make the reservation and close off that
space with this curtain
and it's like they are in their own
little bubble and over in that direction
here we have
some more of the decor here a big thing
here too is uh
having that old school vintage vegas
vibe and this is
actually the only place that is not for
those 21 and over so those who are under
21 can make a reservation probably have
a cold date here
the casino floor though in the hotel
will be 21 and over only
we talked with some visitors and here's
what they said about how they feel about
that
i think that's fantastic because i don't
think this is a place for kids anyway i
come to vegas to be an adult and have
a good time and do all that crazy kind
of stuff so i think that's wonderful
that just makes me love it more
they got me curious to see because i'm
not a huge casino guy but to hear hey
it's 21 and up
and some say circa is a game changer for
sure and here's why
it'll take bragging rights for having
the world's largest
sports book plus the hotel towel will
have
more than seven we'll have 777
rooms and our john is this morning six
pools there that are heated and tourists
told me this is really what downtown
really needed to bring some life back to
fremont street again this opens tonight
at midnight
still ahead in the next half hour we'll
have a live interview we'll talk about
the architecture
the design and what it took to really
build this
property from the ground up here where
there isn't a whole lot of space to work
with
anyway that'll be still ahead live in
the next half hour at 6
30. reporting live from inside circa
hector mejia
alex back to you so cool hector i love
the vintage vibe too
so thank you for showing us all that
we'll see here just a few minutes